das ist die Portugal ja meine
toch filiipe und Monica
Pereira sobald sie pensioniert sind wenn
Sie
zimat mit uns Pension in Portugal könen
wir dann gut leben hier ist leider zu
wenig deswegen viele Portugiese dann
ziehen nach Portugal nach dem pion unter
all ausländische bevölkersgruppe in der
Schwiz ist die portugiesis die einzig W
ab als zur wander verzeichnet blieber
oder gar ke fr
WCH sofort auf Portal da sch und Tschüss
miteinand sie leben und sch aber Herz
Portugal
geverug
ich will W wast Portugiesin und
Portugiese de schwitz und was
zur Monika und der Philippe ihr
Restaurant goau sie sind schon über 20
der schwitz Tochter und vor d Jahr das
restaurantn also wie fest Verm s
Portugal oder gar nicht sch aber
wir haben hier unsere
Leben wie sagt gebaut gebaut oder jetzt
unsere Kinder auch ihre geboren und
jetzt wir denken ihre in der Schweiz
bleibben
immer also bis Pension sicher vielleicht
immer nicht aber bist
Pension ja ich glaub schon das ist ja
der Klassiker man zum Schaffen irgendwie
mit 18 19 20 verlibt sich ja kriegt
Kinder und be der Pension später Wied
das kann ich mal ja ja weil leider hier
in der Schweiz nur mit dem pensionsgeld
also lang nie also ist schwierig oder
und wir dann alles selber zahlen müssen
dann mit unserer Pension in Portugal
können wir dann gut leben hier ist
leider zu wenig deswegen dann viele
Portugiese dann ziehen nach Portugal
nach dem pion viertel Million
Portugiesin und Portugiese leben die der
schwitz noch der italienische und der
dutsche ist es die dritt größte
Ausländergruppe s dem
2017 wird die portugiesis Jasper aber
immer kleiner jedes Jahr Verl über 10000
Person Land meine
Leber so da strukturi oder dann meine K
und meine Kopf steht hier in der Schweiz
ja ich Portugal ist mein Land oder
Portugal ist mE
Land aber dort die kann nicht leben ich
glaube jetzt ich weiß nicht
wie
wie das schwierig
wurdeklen sind die bessere Struktur und
die bessere Möglichkeit Geld Verdi waso
sie da halten er und sieine Frau
schaffen viel und hart unter anderem für
das das ist die
ja wow aber ich habe noch mit paar
Foto groß
ja
viere drei simere
und eine W Wohn sieimmer und das ist für
das K schaffon Machon durch und leich
und Bauer
oder Tochter
jaarbeit für unsere Tochter
oder ich glaube also ich glaube sie will
nicht zurück oder aber dann hat sie eine
Haus sie kann dann verkaufen oder sie
kann da als Ferien Haus haben oder ja
das ist für
Sie also Ihr machen nicht für euch wir
machen auch für euch uns oder wir
überlegen also unsere Helten haben nicht
so viel Geld gehabt dann wir haben
nichts gehabt oder wir müsten von Anfang
alles bauen und dann wenn wir dann
schonis für unsere Tochter haben dann
für sie wird ein bisschen leichter oder
sozusagen ja also ist das denn das
Traumhaus nein nein also ist schon meine
Traumhaus aber meine
ich ja ja ich also wie ich und meine
Tochter wir aber alles
zusammen gesucht also Design ja genau
genau das ist was wir wollten wir haben
genau alles
ausgewählt ja er muss einfach
zahlen das ich
bin die beide h denkt dass so lang schwi
B WR vi für Geld
and das ist der Fall dort spürler im
kantoneroder wo Aurora lergber wohnt im
DF mir vol ganz Familie lergber will sie
ist V 40 Jahr schwi er ist da aufachsen
bürler und sind da Kinder und jetzt
Enkelkinder und bald ist so zum sich
frag nach der Pension g aber auf
Portugal oder bliben wir da ja mal was
sie dazu
s Flag sind schon mal beide Kist auf
jeden
Fall der her
fangt der robert ist ein gebürtiger
Schwier und so ein Ries Fan von Portugal
dass er sich sogar ein portugiesischer
Pass besorgt h undter h die rotgrüne fah
Kist ja die H
immer stürmt verruckt den N ich samab
aber ist
dir Bestandteil von dem
huswench wenn ich wenn ich verkehrt das
Portugal und die
Schwizer schwezer K und der portugies
Fahne da so ja aber
se Portugal schleber hät ich den Schwiz
F und Portugiesisch F dr nein den H die
nur die Portugiesisch ja ke Schwizer
Fahne
nein du verstst diert bin ja schon aber
irgendwi da passt nicht und da passt ja
da passt da h auch viel portugesen im
bürler also da passt sie an wel ja der
freut sicher wenn sie Portugieser
fahenum Dorf geseh
ja drum Hang sie auch
lustig jeder Tag kocht Aurora am Mittag
für die ganze Familie geh bakalau
typisch Portugiesisch V 40 jah s der
Schwiz zum Schaffer und Wegen
robertber und dann
Verw dann denke schon immer so jetzt
muss ich da bben oder denke jetzt bleibe
wahrscheinlich
hier
weil
irgendwie
ja
h schwi besser als bis jetzt h sich
duresetzt zum daie sie se zum
ma J
Schang
ne Kinder kommen mit genau das W beim
awander große Problem beide Kinder und
Enkel h momentan kein Inter Z mitk
Portugal W
[Musik]
vermiss mal den wenn man pensioniert mal
und mal
blibe bis verleid und den kom viicht den
wieder da oder macht halber halben oder
irgendwi da W noch nicht
schwer mal einf Kind ein
zum da muss
mir aber aber schon sind das sind zB
Stund mit dem flüer und dann ist man
wieder
da
ja probier wahrscheinlich aber
schau
komm Thema ist immer wieder im Hause
unter dem Dach W Tochter SAR mitor 14
jah Portugal
schwi zwei Kinder Valentina
und
undug jaigentlich sch ganzüis alles
portugies
wirklichch
ja Inter ganze Babel Portugiesisch ist
wie erklärst du
das Zufall
ja
Schwizer aber irgendwie die Freundschaft
sich Dent und ja und nach halt die ganze
fester wo gegangen sind die sind bber
Freundschaft sind und mittlerwe sind
alle die me Kind undum hat Rela
und die wenig sich tatsächlich überle
zum
zuswander
alle Mario und SAR glücklich Schwiz Herz
für Portugal
sch mit geredet und sie und dem Vater
vor allem he will unbedingt
Portugal schwierig mit der Kinder und so
also du
das Wohnig weil man halt alle dar
gewöhnt sind da miteinand zu wohnen für
Valentina W ein extreme umstellig denke
ich und D für sie ja got Moment merkt
sie noch nicht aber valentina ist so Dr
gro ja W für sie schon Habig man das
schlendlich sie Entscheidig wenn gön ja
und sind zB Stund mit dem flüger dann K
wieder dann geh halt wieder ja also den
frei so viel wie WT aber mir W das
sicher nicht im Weg ST Sel sicher nicht
also wenn s es W machen den S da machen
sicher ja also we bliebe W nicht ja
meine Meinung ist wenn wenn ich Familie
habe da
oder wenn ich Pensionär bin oder ich
denke mache vielleicht dre Monate in
Portugal Monate in der Schweiz immer so
immer so oder wieso wieso bben i eig in
der Schwiz ihr Kön locker auf Portugal
oderin also erstens ich Job W nicht
einfach so
aufge du ich hat Sproch aber den nach
wirklich finde seid hingestellt ja
sicher so viel Verdi wie da und den hat
Kind
jetzt
inskfangen und für mich ist einach
wichtig dass D sch fertig machen m das G
noch 18 Jahre ja ja bis ja bis 18 j ja
also plan ist mit 50 auf scha Schau
wir das Ziel aber man den schllich
wirklich auf Portugal geht weiß man
nicht da wir V abhängig
se genau gich meine
Elter
genau wiederhol
ganzeer wirklich oder
nicht und
PAP also wenn Statistik von den den
portugies portugies zurück Portugal sind
ein Babyboomer wo Pension gönt langsam
wie aber es g vi in eurem Alter wo jetzt
sich sagen Wirtschaft ist B stärker in
Portugal als vielleicht von J und regier
das das Programm Regress wie heißt das
wo wo einem quasi lockt zum zurück auf
Portugal also mir kenn ja als Kollege
ber die sind wieder zurückegangen die
siched und bere jetzt noch drüer schon
wieder das der SCH maacht ja wieso wegen
der einfach mit mit der Struktur und mit
allem zurech also da wo sie sind abockt
ja Vergünstigung undar nicht
be ist und auf dem Lohnsystem und alles
lystem ist ganz
anders s stem Schwiz der Grund weso
viele Portugiesin und Portugiese daiert
oft schaffen sie der
Gastronomie
schff
undzwis GI Geschäft mit fixe Mitarbeiter
und so um
die
auf der baustell schaffen der Alexander
und se Bruder was über halbe jah schwi
s also mit Deutsch
schwierig
okayortugal
inugal
expiortugal so dass er so viel Geld wie
möglich zu Familie schicken kann er
selber got all einhalb Portugal für spte
so wie er mit der Familie Don schaffen
noch einige Portugieser zum Teil
Jahrzehnte lang Dorf und Baus viel
portugies unterwegs sind ist Motivation
und Bedürfnis für viele nicht so groß
zum dutsch lner ich noch
l wo 20 2 jah in der schwitz sind immer
noch rechtut also ich auchut aber
mindest
kom ich ist soer wie findst den du
das ich find
manchm
also nicht so
gut mir
oder Schl Leben mir da in der Schwiz
oder mir le nicht Sportal le in der
Schwiz
m
Mitlied unterhalten
ich Hal sch das normale Leben in die
Schwiz der Antonio mü sich integrier
sprachelernt ein Muss wenn man da
Geschäfte will und so Karriere
gemacht so da ist neu
Lager du hät das in Portugal auch Kön
machen mit gewiss Sicherheit kann ich
sag das
möglich W sind die
Schwiz Wohlstand wo man l verdienen
jetzt
Geld Wirtschaft lauft gut oder schaff
auch
viel nicht langwillig ja durchd das
jetzt mal kaufen aber das in Portugal
machen nein da da kann ich da kann ich
zu 100% zeigen W nicht möglich also du
bist was 30 Jahre Schwiz ja 30 jah genau
bist du ein
Schwizer mal fühle mich Schwizer wenn
denn wenn die unter Schwizer wie die
einzig Ausländer wie und portugies
aber ja in in der Hintergrund ich weiß
woer ich kommt von Portugal
und
beide gich und Auschwitz also da fühle
mich schon ja sicher nur eine V viel
fette wo die Portugiesisch Diaspora h
klar ist bindig V Portugal und schwitz
ist stark was abert Antonio schwizerp
das überrascht m aber nicht Portugiesin
und Portugieser sind eine von den
Ausländergruppe wo seltener als andere
der rote Pass bergend aber irgendwie
passt das ja wenn sich h alle wo ich
können sich gut vorstellen zum Z
irgendwann vielleicht früh vielleicht
später ja ich kann mir nicht vorstellen
wie das ist wenn man Herz so andere Land
h als man ist und schafft ja wie ganz
viele l in der Schwiz oder in anderen
Länder mir W Wunder was sind diefaher
schreib mir Kommentar ich freue mich zum
V dir K und auf Frage zu dem Thema für
Q&A wo wir den nch Woch verladen Video
verlinkt sekos wo back to Balkan gönt
und D ihres Glück versorchen ob das
funktioniert und wieso sie das überhaupt
machen das verzähen sie der Reportage V
impact klick doch ein Mal D alle REC
Reportage findest du übrigens schön
gesammelt be play SRF das ist von dergab
wiren nächst mal bis denn